اذا هذه التغطيه مستمره لتداعيات الزلزال
الذي ضرب تركيا في ساعه مبكره من صباح
اليوم جهود الانقاذ ما زالت مستمره
الارقام وصلت الى اكثر من 250
قتيلا ربما الرقم يصل الى 300 بعد
الاحصائيات الاخيره التي صدرت عن السلطات
السوريه فيما توقفت القائم عند 76 قتيلا
وفق مصادر رسميه تركيا رقم مرشح بشكل كبير
للارتفاع نذكر فقط انه في عام 1999 عندما
ضرب زلزال مماثل تركيا وصل عدد الضحايا
القتلى تحديدا الى سبعه عشر الف قتيل هذا
العام او هذا العام في عام 1999 احصائيه
الاوليه الرقم يقترب من 300 قتيل ما بين
الاراضي التركيه والاراضيه السوريه حسب
الارقام
والاحصائيات الاوليه ما زال العشرات بكل
تاكيد محاصرين تحت عشرات المب التي سقطت
او المباني التي سقطت جرى هذا الزلزال بعض
الاحياء كما نشاهد في هذه اللقطات مع
ساعات الفجر الاولى اشبه باحياء مدمره
وكانها تعرضت بضربه جويه
نشاهد هذه اللقطات حي مدمر بالكامل ومباني
اخرى معرضه للانهيار في اي لحظه كما نتابع
في هذه اللقطات بالتاكيد هناك العشرات من
الاشخاص محاصرين تحت هذه المباني على ان
تصل اليهم بمحاوله انقاذهم فرق الدفاع
المدني نتحدث هنا عن دعوه طوارئ او اعلان
مستوى طوارئ من الدرجه الرابعه في تركيا
وهذا يسمح بمساعدات دوليه فما بالك في
مناطق اخرى متضرره مثلا في سوريا المنقسمه
ما بين سلطات النظام والفصائل
السوريه الاخرى